bien que le freestyle dames je suis pour
ce film la matière est vraiment pour
cette relation entre ce père et sa fille
je crois que c'était une relation assez
forte remarqué quelqu'un qui est bon
évidemment je n'apprends rien personne
mais y rippy la pièce et lumière même
chose pour gloria ses deux filles à ses
2 1
qui sont ces dollars c'est un espèce de
gamins de de 38 ans qui a envie de
déconner tout le temps qui prend rien au
sérieux et puis une gamine qui a les
yeux qui brillent fans à son père parce
que qui a n'a jamais rêvé d'avoir un
père ou une mère qui avait plus envie de
déconner que soi même
oui mais en fait c'est ce passé glorieux
s'amuse beaucoup
comme avec antoine on a du plaisir à
être là on s'amuse ensemble et on prend
notre pied à ce moment là et ça c'est
assez assez qui font puisse y at il
autant rigolé tu sais même pas qui se
passe et qui rigole j'ai vu ces deux
s'amusent ensemble sur la plage d'ansé
se lancer des vannes comme c'était sa
fille en fait comme s'ils avaient passé
leur vie ensemble c'est tous déjà fait
c'est pas compliqué du tout de jouer un
père aimant et admiratif de cette fille
là quoi d'avoir gloria en face pour
jouer ma fille quand j'ai rôle de samuel
c c'est une chance parce que j'aimerais
c'est parce que je la kiffe leur duo il
marche super bien parce qu'en fait
bernard il avait une vraie complicité
il sera gardé de droit dans les yeux il
jouait l'un avec l'autre vraiment
c'était comme une évidence en fait on
sait jamais on sait dira à ce que c'est
la fille de ma race h me pose une
question mais jamais pas une seconde
c'est est immédiat mais gloria un truc
comme ça on est là une étoile un truc et
impalpable qui est un truc elle est
magique cette fille elle magique est vue
comme art est un peu magique aussi ça
fait ça fait une jolie est une jolie
rencontre quoi la chimie tu peux la
travailler tu peux la plaque et un peu
mais pas vraiment c'est
c'est là où c'est paula puis avec gloria
puis samuel groulx est purement c'est le
5 croyable c'est ce qui se passe le tu
peut pas traverser ce champ magnétique
de bonheur là sinon tu vas perdre un
oeil
m'étonnerait que ta mère allait le
visiteur j'espère te filme la matière
est vraiment pour cette relation entre
ce père et sa fille je crois que c'était
une relation assez fort dans ce film
j'étais très heureux de le montrer comme
comme un papa c'est une facette de sa
personnalité qu'on n'avait pas vu au
cinéma c'est à dire une manière d'être
extrêmement généreux de sa personne
envers son propre enfant
sa propre fille en l'occurrence dans le
film est d'avoir une manière de
transmettre très particulière très à lui
avec beaucoup de charme d'humour la
relation entre cet homme là est sa fille
c'est quelque chose d'assez d'assez beau
et donc ça me plaisait de jouer un papa
pour la première fois vraiment puisque
alors on regarde pas comme ça commence
pas
en général on à 9 mois pour s'y faire et
ce qui est plutôt bien foutu et lui bah
en fait il a deux minutes pour s'y faire
du jour au lendemain on lui on lui
flanque sa fille de trois mois dans les
bras
au début ils essayent de s'en
débarrasser vite il se trouve que voilà
il est dir est si je me mets dans sa
peau condamné à être responsables de cet
enfant il l'élève mais en même temps ils
s'élèvent tout seul aussi donc c'est un
peu ça qui se passe il s'élève en
élevant sa fille ce que je dirais
c'était important pour moi que le
personnage de samuel soit quelqu'un qui
devient encore plus enfants que sa
propre fille pour tous les autres il est
fou il est fou irresponsable cinglé et
c'est en ça que je le trouve fort c'est
que il est prêt à à passer pour ça tant
que sa fille heureuse
clem beaucoup il y est sympa il s'amuse
c'est un clown saint cloud n'est très
cool omar avec quelqu'un qui bon
évidemment j'y apprends rien à personne
mais y rit puis la pièce et lui mine
omar a une image à l'extérieur qui est
exactement celle qu'il a dans le travail
c'était assez impressionnant il est
extrêmement honnête sincère droit c'est
quelqu'un qui calcule pas qui est qui
dans le rapport franc avec les gens ils
se posent beaucoup de questions sur les
personnages pas que les siens et se
posent des questions sur tous les
personnages du film parce que ça lui
c'est important pour le sien au moins
c'est le pied c'est que t'as dire que on
est on a des bd journée où on va être
dans la comédie pure des journées ça va
être totalement de l'action il ya des
journées ça peut être un petit peu plus
en profondeur dramatique et tout ça il
ya même des jours où les choses se
mélangent
donc c'est hyper intéressant c'est comme
si on avait plusieurs ateliers quoi à
chaque fois et donc ça c'est sept pieds
pour nous il est créatif il a l'humour
il est agréable enfin je le souhaite je
le souhaite à tous les metteurs en scène
c'est un bonheur travail avec les
combinés il est il est ce qu'on voit à
l'écran enfin voilà après les
incroyables quoi donc de toute façon
qu'est-ce que je dise de plus
on est tous très très très attaché et
ray kroc de gloria pense que c'est le
sait le sait le diamant de cette
histoire c'est son premier film n'arrive
mais mais elle arrive déjà avec quelque
chose d'assez cost oil a une vraie
personnalité d'une intelligence rare
pour une fille de son âge elle ne
comprend vite les choses mais comprend
bien c'est quelqu'un qui est là pour
faire un travail dans le bonheur parce
que c'est enfin quel bonheur facile
mecque et comprend énormément de choses
moi je la regarde puis je fais ok tout
compris des trucs sur le jeu de comédien
qu'il ya beaucoup de la job que je vois
qu'ils ont jamais compris ce top 10 ou
15 mois elle m'impressionne beaucoup
parce qu'elle ait jamais dans la
mignonne reid ont dans l'idée de qu'est
ce qu'on attend d'une petite fille on
est en train de faire une interview
alors s'il vous plaît silence au plateau
c'est pas compliqué du tout de jouer un
père aimant et admiratif de cette fille
là quoi d'avoir gloria en face pour
jouer ma fille quand j'ai rôle de samuel
c'est une chance parce que je la kiffe
je la kiffe gloria je la regarde et j'ai
une émotion elle et j'aime j'aime cette
petite vraiment au mon corps c'est un
bonheur de tourner avec quelqu'un comme
ça parce que pour toi comme comme
comédiens adultes siv en meilleur ça te
rend meilleur parce que tu sens le tue
sans l'intensité de ta partenaire de jeu
de sens sans l'abandon qu'elle a aussi
donc toi sa peau souci ça pousse en
avant
juste tu vas y a rien à faire avec la
bouche en fait c'est juste les yeux qui
sont tristes d'accord c'est super alosi
ce qui a été assez bossé de la voir
prendre confiance au fur et à mesure moi
je vois maintenant elle a vécu go lui
donne une intention c'est digéré ça fait
partie de la scène enfin il ya vraiment
une aisance ses superbes lots sa défense
est dans la place des rats et des singes
est clos parce qu'elle mixe histoire
comique ce soir tu veux que tout le
monde de l'histoire un homme loyal comme
je suis un peu superstitieux elle a
encore beaucoup de choses devraient les
j'ai dit rien mais je lui souhaite
beaucoup je pense que c'est très
prometteur je pense que le loyal et elle
est très c'est une gamine qui est déjà
très inspiré qui est intéressé par un
tas de choses chantenay les dj là je
sens bien que elle a accroché avec le
fait d'être actrice je pense qu'elle va
évoluer là dedans et qu'elle va bien
grandir là dedans on va on va rester
près on va surveiller on l'aidera s'il
faut mais je pense que ça va être malgré
moi maintenant mais j'aurai toujours un
espèce deuil paternel sur elle je pense
qu'il ya un moment dans sa vie ou même
savall a gonflé mais mes jeux forcément
c'est un truc qui va rester dj
antoine bertrand de montréal
j'interprète l'euro de bernis bernie
grand plaisir que j'ai interprétés
bernis et justement je trouve que c'est
dans ma zone de confort dans le dans les
grenouilles ou dans l'espèce de
dramatique et comique aussi faut
comprendre plus l'utilité que ce
personnage le haut c'est-à-dire que sa
peine soit comique dans le film ainsi
stéphane en tant que scénariste est
toujours amusant d'écrire ce genre de
personnage parce qu'on peut se permettre
des choses qu'on peut pas se permettre
avec les personnages protagonistes de
l'histoire
donc c'est des personnages qui sont
toujours très payant parce que on est
content de les voir en tout cas c'est ce
qu'on sait ce qu en espagne
nous sommes inquiets j'avais robert n'y
aura donc pas encore lui ont fait rimer
quand on veut on faire partir quand on
veut et on peut surtout beaucoup
s'amuser avec lui
il dit on coule
dès que tu vois j'ai peut-être envie de
lui faire un câlin quoi ouais génial
surtout moi québec jacques basset
meilleur pas de nos films j'aime bien et
bientôt dans la maison oh mon corps
antoine il a fait des essais il nous a
envoyé des essais du québec
hyper drôle si je mets effet domino qui
fait boule de neige et de fil en
aiguille j'ai flashé immédiatement j'ai
dit c'est lui c'est sûr qu'est-ce qui
sait il serait formidable à côtés d'omar
et où on les a montrés à omark a adoré
aussi également le personnage il est il
est vraiment parfait quoi moi si j'avais
pas eu de rôle de samuel à jouer
j'aurais aimé jouer bernie parce que ces
décès des rôles vraiment vraiment cool à
jouer pour ça il nous fallait le bon
acteur qui comprennent bien ce qui a
joué il fallait l'acteur qui comprennent
bien qu'il n'a pas besoin d'en faire non
plus des tonnes et tout ça pas remarqué
que j'étais un peu banc à tous antoine
il est parfait pour ça il est parfait
comme acteur pour ça il a l'intelligence
et la technique nécessaire pour pour
capter le personnage à bloc
et puis en plus c'est une bombe de mecs
antoine c'est un bonbon c'est à dire que
c'est la gentillesse incarnée le
reprendre oui c'était super déjà les
québécois déjà pour commencer il ya 85 %
du taf qui est fait déjà il est aimé
appel la peine qu il a dit bonjour et
ensuite c'est un mec extrêmement drôle
dans la vie qui est un peu comme le
personnage que je décris de samuel dans
le film joué par omar quelqu'un qui
prend un peu tout à la légère qui
s'amuse de la vie souvent rebih m'agace
attention pas trop non non non non et
patronat après dans le travail antoine
il est très professionnel il déconne
toute la journée mais il est là quand il
faut il connait son ex parc
il a des idées jérémy est rejetée c'est
le partenaire idéal parce que on
s'écoute dans le jeu on est on est on
est vraiment ensemble quand on joue les
scènes et en plus il ya un amour de mec
donc c'est cool c'est vraiment je pense
que on est on est au delà de nos
espérances même avec antoine sur le
personnage de bernis donc ça c'est
vraiment un vrai qui fait pour désigner
bernie je te dirais qu'à un moment donné
jeudi gens parlant d'un mec qui
clairement pas homosexuel mais que sa
palette de virages et il regarde l'eau
puis fait je sens qu'un petit glissade
possible je pense que ça décrit très
bien vernis parce que tout le monde un
potentiel à finir dans son lit
16h et les 18h30 j'ai prolongé parce
qu'ils s'éclatent et ce soir pas de
dépassement d'ancrage kutwa 80 vient
trois heures j'ai viré hockey et l'or
s'est très bien passé ah mais oui oui
christine kristin de bernard challandes
de long voilà c'est ça of course c'est
cool de voir n'y avait que ton bébé
c'est un chien ou est-ce que tu les
connais c'est une bombe
fragments coups de chansons mais
franchement pas assez pour ghabat chabab
voilà c'est à puce à lui se borne à nous
aider à faire ce riche passé puisse
rendre à l'enfance comme septembre
christine carte d'embarquement et
passeports la copine la bussatte
embarquement et passeports mais donc tu
connais qu'une phrase toi j'ai un bébé
sur les bras je trouve pas sa mère j'ai
tout perdu mon portefeuille
j'ai plus de coucher on peut donc parler
français ça m'arrivera vous allez me
sauver l'avenir avec plaisir on n'est
pas à peu près là c'est pas faux cils
changer la vie il ya mes coordonnées pro
et ça c'est perso
tous les duels avez vous la moindre idée
des conséquences et votre éducation sur
gloria la semaine dernière n'est pas
venue du tout ah bon même pas le lundi
art est d'envoyer des faux mails étudie
la mairie kadhafi un matin elle va se
rendre compte que tu es bon depuis des
années et ce à quoi moi ça va réellement
la rend malheureuse
ça a duré huit ans tu sais ce que c'est
huit ans c'est une éternité faut
qu'avant entre à la maison que tout soit
comme avant ça ne va pas être exactement
comme avant
elle est venue pour [ __ ] la merde dans
la famille c'est pas la peine j'ai pas
envie de les rendre malheureuse tue pas
entendre ça loria est arrivé dans ma vie
du jour au lendemain
je n'étais pas prêt
je fais du mieux que j'ai pu
je ne serai plus jamais te promets
et à revenir
je suis juste un peu de temps jetant son
départ